not much but spider-man will be there oh
yeah we were filming in Atlanta right
now it's going very well it's going very
well and every day there are shots there
are images they're pairing of characters
you've never seen before on screen that
again I'm very lucky to do what I do I'm
very thankful to do what I do
and I do it because I eat out for these
moments I kick out for a moment like
this debuting a movie of spider-man in
the MCU for the first time on infinity
war every single shot of every single
scene is a geek out moment straight from
the mouth of bogey you guys have been
asking me for new infinity war death
predictions he also talked about that
being the final chapter for some
characters and talked about the actual
day that the Avengers trailer is going
to drop so this is going to be a
breakdown there's a spider-man giveaway
that's going on now for tickets to the
movie all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video because of all the press that
they've been doing for that Kevin Feige
has been talking about infinity war he
even said when they're going to drop the
trailer and what's going to be going on
with all that footage so a lot of you
been asking me about when he said that
Avengers are going to die during
infinity war I'll clarify what he meant
by that because yes Disney so it's like
are they actually going to kill a
character is that for real something
that they can do just remember that he
is a master at spinning hype without
giving away big spoilers so going down
the list of death predictions basically
what are you talking about is that you
have a bunch of actors that are nearing
the end of their Marvel contract some of
them have react already like Robert
Downey jr. signed a new contract that
went through the 4th Avengers film but
there are some of the other ones that
are reaching the end of their contract
first you're talking about all of the
original a list Avengers its Thor
Captain America Hawkeye Black Widow the
Hulk so there are some of those
characters that they could actually
outright kill and it wouldn't harm
anything like it wouldn't change
anything about the movies they have
planned in the future some of them I
think are 100% safe and then others I
think they'll stick in a deep freeze
except for cameos and other people's
movies there's actually a couple really
cool examples of that during spider-man
homecoming but I can't talk about that
without getting into spoilers so we'll
try to use examples from the
movies just because it's going to be a
while before everybody gets a chance to
see spider-man so right off the bat I'll
say biggest death predictions are Nick
Fury in Hawkeye just two characters do
they haven't used in a long time even
though they're really cool everybody
wants to see a Hawkeye spin-off Netflix
series that would be badass but Jeremy
Renner himself isn't the hugest
box-office draw people aren't clamoring
for a Hawkeye solo movie fans are people
that love Marvel comics but the movies
that they're ramping up to make are
mostly spider-man younger characters the
new people like Doctor Strange Captain
Marvel in the grand scheme of things
Hawkeye is kind of old news and he tried
to retire during Avengers age of Ultron
they pulled him off the farm then he
retired again during civil war and only
came out to help just a little bit so
Hawkeye is already out to pasture it's
kind of the same deal with Nick Fury
samuel l.jackson is really good at
hyping himself up like where's Nick Fury
he's such a badass you should put him in
the movie but he costs about twenty
million dollars a pop so if you're
picking who's going to get that 20
million dollar paycheck Nick Fury isn't
at the top of the list so that is why he
has been D prioritized so he's just not
super essential for the stuff in phase
four but because he's a huge character I
think that gives him a huge moment
during infinity war but Nick Fury had
crazy numbers of life model decoys so
there's always ways to bring back dead
characters and I do think the Doctor
Strange is going to revive someone with
the time gem someone will die like a big
character and then they'll be brought
back to life that is what I think is
going on with Iron Man's character
because I don't think they're going to
do any more legit Iron Man movies
he'll just continue to do the homecoming
thing where he pops up in other people's
movies but when Mikey talks about the
culmination of everything that started
with Iron Man back in 2008 this is
basically his arc he's the one that's
putting the team together he's the ones
that saw the vision of Thanos and all of
his dead comrades
[Music]
so don't be surprised if you see an even
bigger moment like that during the next
Avengers film and in the comics Thanos
ripped iron man's head right off his
body
like literally just popped it right off
like a cherry next on the list is war
machine he did have a romance with
Captain Marvel for a while so the less
you see Iron Man the less you're going
to see war machine but there's a pretty
good chance that he could get a cameo
during the Captain Marvel movie that
happens before the fourth Avengers film
so they might wait to kill off some of
the Avengers or at least put them out to
pasture till the fourth film but Maria
Hill Cobie Smulders I don't think that
she's going to be coming back anytime
soon thor and loki are going to go the
way of Iron Man 2 I don't expect there
to be another Thor spin-off movie but I
do think that Thor is a really big box
office draw so they'll try to use him in
other cosmic movies there might even be
a spider-man Thor team-up in the future
that would be the weirdest most cool
thing ever but Captain America and Bucky
so they're kind of tied to each other
even though I really want to see a Black
Widow Bucky movie that would be so
badass but because Chris Evans is also
at the end of his contract
I think he's eager to do the Robert
Downey jr. thing where he also just pops
up in other people's movies so you've
seen some of the footage from spider-man
homecoming with him giving the funny
lesson the government had to make these
funny PSAs about physical fitness all
kinds of stuff there's a whole bunch of
that that didn't make the final cut of
the film that says they shot a whole
bunch of Captain America PSAs they're
really funny and they'll all be on the
DVD the future of Marvel Studios is
mostly in crossovers in character
synergy team-up movies always do
financially better than solo movies and
it helps keep things from getting stale
you just throw a different character it
like an Iron Man Doctor Strange movie
would feel very different from a Hulk
Thor movie so next on the list to go by
the wayside would be Scarlet Witch
maybe vision I feel like they're going
to change the Avengers roster but I
think that vision will stick around just
because it's such a powerful character
and I think elizabeth Olsen sticking
around just depends on how much she
wants to keep making these movies she's
mostly an indie actress and I think she
enjoys playing the character but the MCU
version of the character just isn't
quite as exciting is what sounds like
Captain Marvel is going to be in Captain
Marvel will be more powerful based on
the way that Feige explained it so when
you're thinking about
characters that they'll get rid of on
the vengers team right now just think
about power redundancies so if you have
two people that are really powerful do
the exact same thing the one that's been
around for a long time is probably going
to go out to pasture but then obviously
you have fan OHS himself I definitely
think they're going to get rid of him in
the fourth Avengers film and even though
he's died in the comics he sort of goes
into the void between realities where
he's not quite dead but he's not alive
he just stuck there until he fights his
way back or gains some other power or
death or someone else gives him some
secret power that enhances him it allows
him to come back to the land of the
living but I don't really expect to see
a whole lot of him after phase 3 is over
I think in phase 4 phase 5 they'll move
into Dormammu being one of the big bads
you have the sovereign in the guardians
of the galaxy there are several
space-based races like the Badoon that
could become really big villains you
still have the Chitauri
so there's plenty of people that could
step up you have people like a nihilist
you could always bring Ultron back
there's just a lot of things going on in
outer space in addition to that O's so
let me know in the comments which big
a-list Avengers do you think are not
going to be coming back after the fourth
film whether they're dead or they legit
just go out to pasture and say you know
what we're not going to do any more
movies we're not going to reset our
contracts the comic-con presentation
hasn't been dated yet but it's typically
on Saturday nights they're going to be
doing a whole bunch of stuff at Comic
Con so whatever footage they drop I'll
do a video for the first public trailer
they'll drop will be with Thor in
November and that's when you'll start
seeing crazy promos for that and black
panther because they're both coming out
within a couple months of each other so
you have infinity war in May but you
have black panther in February so
they'll be promoting the [ __ ] out of
both of those movies starting in
November there's going to be so many
awesome movies and then right after that
Deadpool 2 is dropping in June so leave
all your requests for Marvel videos in
the comments below there's a new Rick
and Morty that I want to do this a new
spider-man Home Coming I'm probably
going to wait to post my spoiler review
for a little while but we're starting to
see a whole bunch of footage from the
infinity war set so if you also want me
to do behind the scenes Avengers videos
just let me know in the comments all
announced the next spider-man giveaway
winner the next time I post Marvel this
weekend that should be in the next
couple of days while you wait for
everything you can click
here for my non-spoilery spiderman
review and you can click here for the
rick and morty season 3 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you